Let me show you something cool.
In Chrome tab tools we can easily open up the source code for a website.
All we need to do is open up DevTools which I will be doing by Cmd+Option+I.
And then we'll go to the sources pane.
Here, in sources,
we can see all of the source code that led to the website we see behind us.
So Index.html should look pretty familiar and we can open up javascripts and
we can see helper.js, jquery and resumebuilder.js.
Let's open up helper.js.
Over here we can see it.
let's give ourselves a little more room, and I'm going to scroll down.
Inside helperjs, we've got all of the strings,
containing the html we want to add to the page.
And we can find some functions down at the bottom.
This job script down here is actually creating the map that we see on the page,
but there'll be more on that in a little bit.
For right now, let's pay attention to this line right here.
Inside this function called locationFinder,
we see this statement that says return locations.
We've seen this return keyword a few times so
far, but we haven't really delved into it's purpose yet.
It's called a return statement, and
its purpose is to make the function give back a value.
>> I think I know what you're getting at.
Won't you explain it a bit more.
>> Well, remember console.log?
It doesn't return anything, which means if we were to create a new variable,
like this.
Var hello equals console dot log hello will get undefined when we try to run it.
We wee that console dot log worked and
printed hello, but then we see this undefined below it.
If we try to examine the variable later by just typing out hello and
pressing enter, we see undefined.
That's because console dot log didn't return anything,
it didn't give anything back.
However, most functions actually do return values.
>> Like a lot of string methods?
>> Yeah, let's look at string dot split.
First we'll create a string like this one.
I've created a string called myString and
set it equal to, This is my favorite string!
Then we are going to go ahead and separate the string on spaces.
Meaning that we'll get each word by itself.
Split works like so.
It's going to act on the string here.
And it's going to separate it based on the parameter here.
This parameter is just a single space so
we should get an array of the words from myString.
Let's go ahead and save it to the variable myArray and press enter.
Okay, and when we try to access myArray, we see and array of strings.
This, is, my, favorite, string.
Each of the words from myString before.
In other words,
split returned an array of strings which is now equal to myArray.
>> Oh, I see!
When we write functions that we want to turn into a value,
they must give us back a value.
Looking at this function as a whole.
The parameter is the input.
The function does something using that parameter on the actual string and
then it gives us some sort of value.
>> Let's think about the resumes j's on data and all the location in it.
For this quiz I want you to write a function called locationizer.
It's going to take in the work object.
Locationizer should return an array of the locations in your work object.
Remember work contains all the jobs that you've had in the past and
each one of which should have a location associated with it.
We want you to return an array of those locations.
You might find it's helpful to use the array.push method which
is going to add values to the end of the array.
When you get to the quiz,
you'll see a sample json that your code will iterate through.
Good luck.